أخذ حيوان الخدمة النفاثة
مهاراته العلاجية إلى آفاق جديدة
عندما سرج إلى الدرجة الأولى مع
معالجه ، تحقق من هذا
[موسيقى
] وهو حصان علاجي مصغر اسمه
فريد يأخذ رحلته الأولى على الإطلاق مع
معالجته رونيكا فروز بينما كان
يرتدي ما  يبدو وكأنه نيسيي مناسب
لبطل خارق ، إنه في الواقع غطاء
لحماية الركاب من الحساسية التي
غادرناها في فترة ما بعد الظهر ، سافرنا من غراند
رابيدز واتصلنا في دالاس
ثم ذهبنا إلى أونتاريو بكاليفورنيا ،
كانت التجربة أفضل بكثير مما كنت
أتوقعه فريد  تم تدريبه
ليكون حيوانًا
علاجيًا وحيوانًا خدميًا ، فهو يعيش مع رونيكا وعائلتها
ولديها إعاقة وتستفيد من
تدريب فريد ، كما تدير رونيكا مؤسسة
غير ربحية حيث تقدم الخيول الفريدة وغيرها من
الخيول العلاج المساعد للآخرين
المحتاجين وهنا  يمكنك أن ترى فريد يزور
الأطفال في مستشفى العام الماضي يستمتع الأصدقاء بشكل
لا مثيل له لرؤية الابتسامة
، ولهذا السبب نفعل ما
نفعله بالطبع روني  تقول كا إنها تأمل
أن تساعد رحلة فريد الأولى في تقليل وصمة
العار المرتبطة بالسفر مع
حيوانات الخدمة والتأكيد على أهمية
التدريب المناسب ، فهو خارج عن السيطرة ،
إنها عملية إساءة استخدام كبيرة ، فهناك
الكثير من حيوانات الخدمة غير المدربة
على متن الطائرة.  أمضيت عامًا من حياتي في
تدريب هذا الحصان على نطاق واسع على
ما لديه ، وكنا على
استعداد تام لكل شيء يركض هذا الفحل اللطيف الذي
ينشر التعاطف داخل
وخارج الأرض في قلوبنا
هنا على البضائع